even though boys in the hood is not a
documentary
but it's so close to one the temptations
in a place like compton it's much is
much
more than the temptations in iowa for a
kid
i mean it's this close from a
documentary because
it's so real oh we got a problem here
we got a problem here you know it's a
movie about
who we are you know and we love to see
ourselves on screen
because it shows that what needs to be
said
is getting said especially by john who
who lived in south central los angeles
writing a movie you know it's not
hollywood's interpretation of what
life is in south central this is this is
a young brother from the streets
who who uh you know just called it like
he saw it
either they don't know
don't show
i don't care about what's going on in
the hood the problem don't start when
they're teenagers
the problems start when they're real
young the only thing that's that's
teaching them about life is the streets
or the television
so what they do is go outside and hang
with people who respect them
you know they have a sense of belonging
to something you know other than their
family so that's why
it becomes a family you know the gang
members the older people and the gangs
become these fathers it's my pops
he's the one who uh put it down on me
when i messed up
you know i saw a lot of myself in the
film you know but see i had a father
there
whenever i went on the wrong path he
would knock me on the right path you
know that's the reason i didn't get
caught up i still live in south central
la i gotta stay there because
that's where i'm from and that's why i'm
always be
the black community needs what i have to
offer
to the community more than beverly hills
do so you know i gotta stay
i gotta stay with my people and you know
that's gonna keep my edge there
yo cuz i
i know why you got the car last night
shouldn't have been there in the first
place you know it picks them up when
they're 10 years old
you know in the film you could tell
which kid is going to go the right way
and which kids are going to go the wrong
way
i mean kids are curious kids want to be
independent
they want to do what they do all you
have is is poor kids trying to get rich
because this country says it's not all
right to be poor
so it shows that what we got to do is
take care of our kids real young
and teach them good values or whatever
and
you know everything will be all right
doing exactly what they want you to do
you have to think young brother about
your future
it made me look at my son differently
because you know i don't have the time
to spend with him
right now that i want to spend with him
because you know i'm handling business
but
you know every every moment that i get
with him you know i think about
my son and who he is who i want him to
become because
now i know the streets i know what he's
going to be tempted with so
you know i'm just instill what i have
what i know in him
and hopefully he'll hear take the right
path i know that
you know i have a son now that by me
seeing
this film put together i know exactly
what i what i have to do as a father
to to definitely be a father to my son
you know and raise him right you know
just open my eyes hey dope
what's up
you still got one brother left man well
you know everybody loves the film
because it's a film about people and it
helps you better understand who
who we are in in south central los
angeles in the inner city
you know why the problems are there and
you know when you understand people you
respect
each other and you know that's how
people live together